first of all thank you for letting me be
your neighbor and bring you some cake
thank you so much I took the it's a
really good cake I took the bunt home
yeah yeah I put ice cream on top of it
oh my gosh it's too much that was too
much sweetness I should just literally
will bring like a like a mixing bowl
well he's the most fit looking skinny
individual and cut him in his sleep and
then yeah it's always a vat of ice cream
have you gotten a bunt yet no why'd you
bring it up for my neighbors and you
weren't like please go away
but anyways so this is something I find
interesting that I didn't actually know
you're in a band I mean you're always
kind of cool in rockers I didn't know
cuz it was dress performing under the
name Joseph the spouse it's a lot of
kind of country blues folk stuff and
we've just started playing around Los
Angeles and we'll have an album
forthcoming soon
[Applause]
Taylor Goldsmith the lead singer and
songwriter for a band called dogs yeah
and so he and I've been writing some
songs together that's great that's great
he got the the guys together to come
record on the record and play a lot
about I think so
okay okay well I got a taste of you're
seeing a few weeks ago just take a look
ya'll I wanna know cuz I know this is us
the show but like who are you that's
right dog or cat person
dog coffee or tea coffee tea yeah can
you sing your favourite musical notes in
your favorite key middle C
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like that breath support is crazy you
held it forever
I hope the note and it stayed in tune I
think I know it did long I was so tired
not a touch of vibrato that actually is
harder straight tone another broader
thank you Kelly Clarkson we would have
totally been choir nerd friends I love
absolutely so you dress like a rut girl
the time to he showed up with these
really flies sunglasses that I wish she
would have went out over there so cold I
like steampunk a bit we'll get a little
bit later they're so cool you always
have great fashion we appreciate it
we have some pictures that we love
[Applause]
you say where do you find a suit like
that and the depths of the Internet I do
I have a favorite one though we brought
we have a favorite one that I love I
would have totally found out even where
I love guardians of the galaxy have you
seen guardians of the galaxy I know I'm
a superhero I'm not he is so funny
coming from huge superhero fans what you
like what you like snow freak over and I
love your taser face dumb face and a
good heart okay so this is Toby you know
and in the show you have your new TV dad
you have a baby no yeah so have you ever
do you like Alison you change the diaper
right well luckily on set we don't I
don't have to change any of the diapers
and when you're a TV dad you know it's
like there's like multiple children we
have triplets we had twins on the show
that I did write that looked nothing
alike by the way I'm like there's one
because babies can only work like 13
minutes a day which is a appropriate
amount of work to make a baby do because
they didn't sign up but no I don't
change any of the diapers I think that's
unfair I want to see an Instagram of you
changing a diaper
you have a little boy then you got to
make sure that diaper goes on quick
let's just put a sure
have you been peed on in the face I have
I'm sure I have got that thing on quick
you know this is getting don't they have
like little caps do I use like you know
those pads when you're when you're
breastfeeding those little Pat yeah I
just yeah it can get kind of messy I
want I want a messy diaper that you have
to change that's how that's the kind of
friend I am up you know what I'll do it
okay okay so here's to do you say to
your son cuz you're talking about you
know dogs you know the band you love
yeah I do we sweet sing a song to him
every night this Dean Martin song which
I keep secret I'll tell you later I just
you know it's his lullaby subtle but
then my mom sings to him and soon as she
walks in the door she's like pizza or
pizza or a pizza cheese does she make up
songs yes nickname sings and she's so
loud my my grandpa who's named after
also Howard as his middle name used to
sing this song to me like he Kalina
Donsky Kalina Dunst we love you Kiki
Leena done ski Lincoln so she does that
with any hi Pete any hi peewee but she
didn't take a what Kiki Kalina done key
Kalina I don't keep Elena was smoking
something I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this